رقعه المعارك تتسع في السودان عده مواقع
باتت مسرحا للاقتتال سواء داخل العاصمه
الخرطوم او خارجها فخريطه الصراع مليئه
بالنقاط الساخنه اكثر المعارك شراسه تدور
راحها بالعاصمه الخرطوم ابرزها مقر
القياده العامه للجيش والذي يوجد في شمال
العاصمه فالاقتتال مستمر في محيط مقر
القياده وسط انباء متضاربه حول جهه
المسيطره على المبنى مبنى اخر في العاصمه
الخرطوم تحول الى ساحه صراع بين الطرفين
وهو مبنى القصر الجمهوري الذي يوجد في
المنطقه الشماليه من العاصمه ولا يزال
الوضع غير واضح هناك فقوه الدعم اعلنت
سيطرتها عليه قبل ان ينفي ذلك الجيش
السوداني شمالا دائما لكن هذه المره في
الضفه الاخرى من نهر النيل وتحديدا ام
درمان حيث دارت اشتباكات في محيط مبنى
التلفزيون بعد محاوله قوات الدعم السريع
السيطره عليه لكن الجيش السوداني فيما بعد
سيطرته على المبنى بشكل كامل مجهضا
محاولات قوات الدعم وبعيدا عن العاصمه
الخرطوم وهذه المره في شمال البلاد
وتحديدا في مدينه مرويا التي شهدت اندلاع
الشراره الاولى للازمه فمصير مطار مروي
الذي يقع في الجزء الشرقي من المدينه لا
يزال معلقا في ظل اعلان كل طرف بسطه
سيطرته عليها والاكيد ان حرب المدافع
والاسلحه في السودان توازيها حرب معلومات
اسلحتها المقاطع المصوره والبيانات
وسام الذهبي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات